my name is Miriam Pross net and I was on
Team heatwave you play and there are
characters moving around and different
people who are at risk for being
vulnerable to heat waves move around the
screen so one person was in charge of
researching who are those people
and another person was in charge of okay
I'm gonna make a character object and we
split up all of those actually right at
the beginning so that we knew who to
contact about what and then based off of
that we would come together and say what
needs to be done and whose job is it and
is that still balanced in terms of who's
working on what and it worked out really
well actually
actually funny enough I took this course
solely because I had no course sake no
computer science courses this semester
because I was abroad last year I did a
full year of engineering coursework and
I was like don't need any more
requirements might as well just take one
for fun so here I am in creating video
games and so my goal was to write code
and the funniest thing I'm not
representative of my team at all I'm
like the one person in this class he was
not written a single line of code this
entire semester because I ended up being
project manager a lot and so what I
learned is a lot of the process a lot of
making things work is really just
emailing people calling them on the
foaming like are you supposed to be at
this meeting right now going and buying
snacks for a meeting you think it's like
silly you know nobody really needs to
get snacks but I've been told by my
teammates that if I hadn't gotten snacks
they wouldn't have come so I learned a
lot about the project management and the
work that goes on behind the scenes
which I've seen before but I just didn't
realize the scale of it in games ah
something I would give feedback about
this class I'm really like the fast pace
of the first three project and this
project because it was so much longer
time the team was so much larger and we
had this kind of set topic we had to
deal with I didn't enjoy it as much as I
mentioned one of the main issues for our
team was passion at the end of the day I
I can summarize what you should do in a
heatwave and like two sentences that
doesn't make for a very interesting game
ah so that's something I would say if I
was to do it again I would I would have
played the game where you play as the
heatwave and you like try to attack
people because that sounds like more fun
I think that's the other thing I learned
about games is that you really have to
care about what you're making
well somebody mentioned in one of the
presentations that for the last project
we would submit these print tasks lists
and they wouldn't necessarily be what we
like people actually would do because
people were so busy at the end the
semester for my team if it was the case
that we hadn't done something I would
put it on the sprint task list again but
I didn't have to and that could have if
I hadn't done that then there would have
been a big divergence between what we
said we were doing what we were actually
doing so as an educator I would really
say check in on your team see actually
what they've done make sure they're
setting realistic goals and following
through on them